hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning
podcasts from Monday October 28th 2019
what's going on how are you doing how
was your football Sunday did you did
your team win did your team your college
team win on Saturday if it did are you
in a better mood if it didn't did you
take it out on your whole life
god dammit Sally I told you not to get
up out of that chair second you did they
threw [ __ ] interception goddamn woman
so [ __ ] stubborn I didn't watch much
of any football this week and I didn't I
watched LSU dad I got beat [ __ ]
Auburn on say it's a great game I think
LSU filee Wardell there Dave let's I
don't know the big thing they gotta be
[ __ ] Alabama they just gotta they got
to go in and they just got to take Nick
Saban by what's left of the hair on top
of his head and they they got to swing
him around like a [ __ ] a weapon in the
goddamn in uh Middle Ages I don't know
what they have to do but it's just no
matter I know they're undefeated I know
they played well but until you beat
Alabama you know this in two weeks they
got next week off they got they got 14
days to stare at that goddamn game on
the calendar did they have too much time
do you think they were over prepared is
this this is a case of over preparedness
coach would you say that excuse me coach
I've never coached even at a little
league level I was just wondering do you
feel like you over prepared your
professional team I guess college isn't
professional you wouldn't nobody amount
of money that make enough of it huh
goddamn big business isn't it
the [ __ ] was I just gonna look up I was
literally trying to think my way through
that thought as I subtly went to the
search it's gonna look something up I've
[ __ ] left it left me where did it go
anyway guess what I had some [ __ ] to do
today but there's a fire this time of
year there's all the fires and this year
there's also crazy winds so it's it's
[ __ ] scary I don't know one of these
years I'm telling you I just feel like
the whole [ __ ] thing's just gonna go
up like [ __ ] flash paper you know I
know it looks worse though it looks
worse when you watch it on TV I always
have relatives calling me up being like
yeah you all right out there it's just
like I can't even see the smoke you know
it's it's that far away but I had some
business to do it business in Santa
Monica today and I just said [ __ ] that
I'm gonna stay out of the way the people
that I have to go out and go fight those
damn pigs how can you [ __ ] imagine
since 2:00 a.m. the thing broke out
they've been sitting in standing in the
[ __ ] hills on uphill fire you know
bad enough on level ground you got a
hiker you got to go on a hike with all
of that gear on and then you got to go
up there and the [ __ ] winds are
whipping it around it's amazing that
they ever even get the things out before
everybody dies so any words really weird
that it sits over there again because
they just had a fire there last year and
I was thinking the upside of that is if
you didn't lose your house there was a
fire there and it kind of burned
everything down so there was nothing
else to get to catch on fire I thought
because last year it jumped the highway
this [ __ ] I tell you I absolutely
love Los Angeles but I'm telling you
like you you definitely pay for the
weather out here you don't stay yin and
the yang you can't have your [ __ ]
cake and eat it it's if the weather's
gonna be this nice so you think you're
gonna miss out on winter here's a
firestorm how about that huh you still
think Hale is that bad that buddy
so when it was obviously I hope that
they put that out soon so I'm actually
feeling guilty now because now I [ __ ]
cancelled everything that I had to do
this afternoon out there and I found
myself and people are risking their
lives this is how selfish human beings
are or maybe I just am I was literally
in the kitchen as I was making myself a
couple of soft cooked eggs I just
started singing to myself I got the
whole day to myself I got the whole damn
day to myself that's what I'm singing
because literally like [ __ ] whatever
15 20 miles away these people go up
screaming through [ __ ] those [ __ ]
air masks and I'm singing see that you
know maybe it isn't because I'm selfish
maybe because I'm just that positive now
[ __ ] I realize I got somebody a couple
of friends who live over there should do
this I hate doing that [ __ ] like when
someone's going through some major [ __ ]
like that and you just like well I guess
anything you need and this would be good
because they could actually come and
stay at your place you could actually do
something you know but we know when
someone's going like you know they had a
death in the family you know if there's
anything I could do could you you know
let me know yet could you bring the
person back to life yeah it didn't think
so alright then thank you
we got enough [ __ ] fruitcakes I hate
those moments because I refuse to write
like a soundbite and then you got to sit
there for like 40 minutes how do I write
something sincere then you realize that
this is why this thoughts and prayers go
out to the survivors uh you let us all
out tonight baby hold your kids a little
closer I can't believe people say that
with the [ __ ] look of sincerity on
there fits the most insincere thing you
could probably say at this point could
say considering it now it's just a total
cliche thoughts and prayers go out to
the survivors and the victims of the
surviving victims for survivors with the
children being held closer during these
times of this current climate living our
truth being warriors I know just
covering all your [ __ ] bases so I
actually thought for half a second I was
like you know what maybe I'll go see the
[ __ ] joke or kill the Irishman I was
thinking maybe that you know it's crazy
we're watching all these fires and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just sitting there
watch them they're gonna shut the
[ __ ] power off for like a million
people out here because they're worried
with the winds a wind condition like 90
knots or something [ __ ] insane like
that which is almost you know 50 knots
is a jet stream so this is almost twice
that they're worried what it's going to
do with these fires and if I guess if
the electricity is turned on it can
cause even more far as it sounds like a
smart thing but somehow I got a feel
like the rich people don't get their
power turned off you know I'm telling
you man I got there's a guy down the
[ __ ] Street who has solar panels I
gotta talk to this guy I gotta get it
man you know you got to get off this
[ __ ] the [ __ ] oil companies are not
all Billy's preach enough oh look at him
he doesn't even [ __ ] read if maybe as
an individual that's what you need to do
if you got you know I don't know if you
got to do something it's just sitting
here waiting for politicians to finally
stand up to banks and oil companies I'm
realizing it's just never gonna happen
no matter if the president has a red tie
a blue tie a clam a [ __ ] a combination
of both a him/her or are they it's just
not gonna [ __ ] happen okay
they sent the message in the 60s if you
rock the boat crazed lone gunman comes
in and [ __ ] takes you out so well I
think it has to go from the bottom up
rather than the top down so I don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] like how much more
crazier does a goddamn weather have to
get in and people keep sending me this
[ __ ] information I hate talking about
this [ __ ] cuz then people send me all
this crazy [ __ ] information with like
no solution just to let you know this
has happening
so now I think I'm doing the same thing
whatever I'm just gonna try to be nice
to people get some solar panels and uh
you know not brandish a weapon although
I don't think it's the worst thing I
think if you're a good guy oh my god I'm
doing the NRA a good guy with a gun and
gegege yeah
the only thing that stops a bad guy with
a bazooka is a good guy with a bazooka
the one that you stopped a pedophile is
a good non pedophile [ __ ] minute I've
got an adult consensually what Oh
[Laughter]
bring back the insane asylums they're
gonna put people in there they gotta get
they got to get it back to got to get
the rubber rooms back in there you know
what I mean we got to bring it on home
we gotta bring it on a whole business if
I was running for president we're gonna
bring everything home in the next one
the next the next four to eight years
I'm in office we're gonna bring it home
we're gonna stop trying to save the
world wink wink nod nod saving the world
you know what I mean we're saving the
world why don't we come home take care
of our own people you know I think
that's what Trump wants to do I think he
wants to bring all the troops back so
they can you know sweep the forest is so
we stop having fire soon I know I have
no solutions let's talk about sports is
there anything better than sports
because it keeps your mind off of what's
really important that you have no
control over how about those Green Bay
Packers
but did it or did it at all of these
[ __ ] people acting like the Patriots
are just this no man you know I don't
know what that [ __ ] deal is Green Bay
looks great New Orleans look great 49ers
and I think the 49ers are sort of the
Patriots of the West now before 49er
fans get it excited
what I mean is you have a very
impressive record but who have you
played I don't know Kevin Hart
alright 49ers there we go but the
schedule let's see who they've played so
far this year all right of course all
they have is the rest of the goddamned
[ __ ] year come on man can't you just
can't you just tell that I'm too dumb to
[ __ ] search for what I want wait
49ers 2019 regular season schedule wipe
up leper boda boda alright they played
the Cleveland Browns not impressive
no offense they played the Rams
that's impressive went to the Super Bowl
last year it's impressive in week two
right no wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I start the wrong tone ok they
played the Buccaneers you know
Buccaneers they're a jekyll-and-hyde
team they beat the Bengals the Bengals
stink they beat the Steelers in a close
game but you know the Steelers are the
Steelers just show up in like this is
what we're doing and then you adjust to
it some even in the second quarter and
then they come out in the third quarter
they like we're still doing it
beat the Browns that impressive beat the
Rams
actually they beat the Browns way easier
than the Patriots didn't although we had
a pretty easy game yesterday even though
I didn't watch a [ __ ] second of it
because I refused to get the NFL Sunday
Ticket I don't give a [ __ ]
I've tried enough times I'm not [ __ ]
doing it [ __ ] DIRECTV you know what I
kind of like going back to only having
one or two [ __ ] games it's kind of a
nice thing and having time to
contemplate my life anyways then they
beat the Redskins
that's a weird game 9 to nothing
what Redskins have only won one game
this year against the hapless barely in
the league Miami Dolphins then they
kicked the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
Panthers yesterday 51 to 13 all right
they got the Cardinals they're a good
team they got this Seattle Seahawks with
old sneaky pete they got him they got
the packers they got the Saints see I'm
telling you they got the Seahawks again
they got the Rams again see this they're
right here yeah I'll tell you right now
these San Francisco 49ers are as far as
the schedule goes this year which is a
it's a really weird year there's like
four good teams the parody this year is
everybody sucks
generally speaking nobody's really that
good it seems so I was gonna say as far
as the being the Patriots of the the NFC
West is the NFC West the NFC and what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
is they've had like this Alabama Crimson
Tide sort of [ __ ] schedule where
there's a lot of [ __ ] Bowling Green's
you know no offense Ohio State of Miami
type of games and let's see what the who
the Patriots got and we got the Ravens
we got Kansas City Kansas City with
three [ __ ] losses all of a sudden
Jesus Christ it's almost like if Patrick
mahomes gets hard they're not the team
that they were but I guess people are
already talking about their defense
saying it wasn't that [ __ ] good Jesus
Christ what a goddamn throw by Aaron
Rodgers huh I'll tell you if Tom Brady
wasn't so much better and better looking
no kidding they're both [ __ ] amazing
but come on Tom Brady you know if they
were making a movie all right I'm not
saying Aaron Rodgers would be a bad guy
I would say that he would be like Tom
Brady's the lead I would say Aaron
Rodgers is the second lead all right and
that dude down in Jacksonville would be
the guy they're trying to catch
his [ __ ] his bad guy mustache Kansas
City Chiefs I don't know five and three
I think that a little better than that
record despite some steps forward that
Chiefs defense has to do more Arrowhead
pride Arrowhead pride okay you gotta
believe that that sounds like some
hardcore [ __ ] Chiefs fans have you
ever bent by the way is anybody
listening to the podcast other than
people who live in the Kansas City
Missouri area
have you been to Arrowhead Stadium
that's one of the great ones I ever went
to and that really is the loudest
Stadium in the league there is loud as
Seahawk fans in an old-school stadium we
actually you had to have you had to be
loud because of how much you cared you
know not because Bose built your [ __ ]
stadium when am I gonna let it go
never never
alright and then I watched that f1 race
yesterday I got to watch the MotoGP
unfortunately I already saw the
highlight on the love the last lap I
mean I'm telling you I'll tell you right
now if you're in racing
MotoGP is where the [ __ ] it's at I know
it's over I know Marc Marquez is won the
title I know that Honda has won the
builders championship or whatever but
still it's just the best [ __ ] racing
out there but I watched the f1 yesterday
and it's it's literally it's becoming a
sport to watch Ferrari [ __ ] the whole
thing up I just don't get like I don't
understand you have pole position and
you have second place you maintain that
through the first three [ __ ] laps
how does neither one of those cars cross
the finish line first how do you know
that Lewis Hamilton and Mercedes are
gonna somehow figure out they just did
just [ __ ] it's like Bill Belichick
[ __ ] where the other team's better you
know they got this they got that they
got a home field they already beat the
page
it's once he just goes in he's just
smarter he just comes up with a better
game plan that's what that's what
Mercedes did by looking at exactly what
Ferrari could have looked at how well
Daniel Ricciardo was doing on the Hajj
[ __ ] what are they go hard surface
tire whatever they call it the hard tire
it wasn't getting chewed up at that
altitude I don't know what the [ __ ] they
saw but they saw it early they had him
Pitts early I was like what the [ __ ] are
they doing
and then few laps later like oh my god
they did it again they did it again they
they absolutely 100% deserve it and III
actually lose my mind rooting against
Lewis Hamilton just because it's fun to
do I'll say if you want to be bored and
watch f1 route for Mercedes and Lewis
Hamilton you're gonna nod off during the
[ __ ] races alright unless especially
if he has pole position but rooting
against them you'll be off your couch as
you're screaming about the inevitable
that he's going to come back and win the
[ __ ] race it's really it's really
incredible I don't know I think Enzo
Ferrari needs to come back from the
[ __ ] grave and he needs to start
treating the [ __ ] team the way you
know they used to where I told you I
read that [ __ ] book and it's like are
you alright you're our driver now why is
there a hole in the in the floorboards
oh because the last guy got decapitated
in this car and he bled out and we had
to get the blood out of it alright
you're up next
that was like that the running thing
when when when he would hear that one of
his drivers died he would nod and then
his first question was how's the car he
can't do that now and the progressive
world of sports anyway last night I did
a live podcast that I actually thought
was gonna be that was also filmed that'd
and all of that [ __ ] that's going to be
coming out I some time this week
very
excited about it I went out there and I
was like it's weird it's like you're
doing a comedy show but you don't have
any material but uh the crowd was
amazing thank you to Andrew chthamalus
for setting the whole thing up thank you
for everybody down there a dynasty
typewriter that uh it was just an
incredible event it's something that I I
think I want to maybe start doing I
think I want to maybe start doing this I
sound like the [ __ ] chick in your
life like ah god what is she saying
where is the solution that I can give
her to end this conversation as quick as
possible
yeah I want to start doing those things
and I'm thinking maybe I'll do the next
one you know if I have like a road gig
or something like that I'll try and
figure out a way to do something like
I'm thinking my next one
oh is this see this is why my [ __ ]
this is why everybody who's you need to
become a stand-up comedian because you
get to [ __ ] do searches like this all
right bill burr Las Vegas okay
yet the dududududu did it it did it it
when the [ __ ] am i playing there what
the [ __ ] is my website I get [ __ ]
hunted out of all these goddamn content
who's in a new world I don't bomb yeah
dddd tour dates December 21st Jesus
Christ I'll have to be there in a
[ __ ] Santa Claus hat alright so I'm
in Vegas December 21st all right now
let's look at something else here okay
Vegas nights schedule okay this right
here this was I'm gonna convince all you
guys right now to become a stand-up
comedian
cuz this cuz what this is what your life
this bread and circus right here could
be your life alright their next home
game they have one on Monday the 23rd so
okay
[ __ ] god damn it Saturday Sunday I'm
like a static kid I could possibly do
the Saturday do a [ __ ] podcast on
Sunday and then go to the game on Monday
and I don't know seems like a lot of
time to meet maybe I'll do that who
knows all right maybe you don't want to
be a comedian that whole thing was
supposed to [ __ ] work out and it did
not and I blame the conservative
Democrats of the Republican Party why do
I keep talking in a southern accent I
don't know why it's soothing to me I
don't know what it is I actually uh I
like the South you know I'm white they
don't have a problem with me down there
I feel welcomed I'm joking
all right let me see here doo doo doo de
doo doo doo doo I allegedly had some
reads for this week I apologize this
whole podcast is falling apart cuz I've
already got birdie I feel like I've
already worked and then they called me
back in all right oh here's a bunch of
[ __ ] questions oh I don't know if he
reads I'm gonna be advertising uh I got
a little loose with the lips and all of
a sudden everybody goes to the [ __ ]
runs out into the streets and I have
nothing to talk about he's a deal this
podcast is you can tell it's going off
the rails it might be a little bit short
this week all right might be a little
bit short this week but know that I'm
gonna make it up with a live video
podcast this week okay plus the Thursday
afternoon podcast bill we don't need
excuses we need laughs we're stuck in
traffic I have fired jumping over my car
from one side of the four or five to
another could you please come with a
little bit of funny all right Mercedes
wagon
hey that Merc wagon you were talking
about
check out Lewis Hamilton on Letterman on
that Letterman show on Netflix he gets
Hamilton to do some laps in that wagon
and let's loose get the [ __ ] out of here
that's amazing why don't I you know I'm
done I'm done rooting against Lewis
Hamilton I'm done I guess said it was
never [ __ ] personal although he's a
little bit of a baby sometimes you know
what he expects out of his teammate
versus what he's willing to do for his
teammate all right Lewis Hamilton
Letterman Mercedes Lewis Hamilton and
the [ __ ] station wagon oh my God look
at that thing that's oh he just Louis
Hamilton just said that station wagon is
a great car [ __ ] this I'm sending this
to virzi right now the greatest Formula
One racecar driver of right now who
knows by the end of his career whether
he's gonna be on that just said that
station wagon is a great [ __ ] cooker
hot damn it although he also works for
the company all right now I'm less
excited you know if it was a Ferrari
station wagon back yeah you know I don't
know we should probably check what kind
of tires they're gonna be running on
today ah that was a low blow anyway
I like I [ __ ] love that car I mean
that it's an exciting car to look at
it's it's like one of those cars you
look at it it's like it's moving when
it's just sitting there we get it bill
you enjoy the car well [ __ ] you I get
excited about things like station wagons
I'm a dad now I can do that right don't
dad shame me all right let me get back
to where the hell was I at the con okay
Obama's speeches dear Billy plant-based
tits do you realize the thought that
just went into that insult it's like I
can't call a Billy fat tits anymore I
can't call a billy booze bag anymore so
now he's gonna shame me you know what I
gotta tell you so I've been getting more
goddamn compliments about how good I
[ __ ] look you know I have great genes
I'm aging the way I'm aging and all of
that I'm - all I've done is well I
changed my diet - but I basically I just
[ __ ] laid off the booze booze [ __ ]
kills you man you know
weed makes you look sleepy but boozed it
just [ __ ] it takes the [ __ ] life
out of you you know you start looking
like some [ __ ] may seed a [ __ ] red
face I don't know something that scares
children on Thanksgiving all right dear
Billy plant-based tits I'm tired that's
that's up there that's top five that I
can remember recently not all of Barack
and Michelle speaking tours are to
receive kickbacks from their corporate
overlords I never said that I never said
that I'm just saying that they go and
take that blood money that's what I'm
saying before you sit there and tell me
about the other [ __ ] things that he
does and how come you didn't take time
to [ __ ] look up some of the speeches
that somebody with the red tide looks at
for example my mother and brother saw
Barack Obama at the downtown arena in
Winnipeg downtown [ __ ] and Irina
Winnipeg earlier this year it was a
sold-out event and full of people from
all walks of life it was more of an
opportunistic cash grab on Obama's part
than something nefarious as you're
constantly suggesting I'm not suggesting
it's happening just another perspective
for you to consider I [ __ ] give up
with you [ __ ] people or people like
you I [ __ ] give up do you really
think we're over there
saving the Iraqi people do you really
think Iran is picking a fight with us do
you really think that they would be
picking a fight with us if they weren't
sitting on top of a product that was
worth billions of [ __ ] dollars I just
I don't I don't [ __ ] get it I don't
know how many times these [ __ ]
politicians on both sides of the aisle
can [ __ ] you over I don't know how many
speeches they have to give to these
[ __ ] people and then all they need to
do is just do one [ __ ] gig that this
is to cover their [ __ ] their bases he
should be Arab all right
you know what yeah you're right you're
right there you go yeah okay [ __ ] it you
know he just gave he just gave a speech
to a couple of [ __ ] banks
a part of the 2008 scandal took their
[ __ ] blood money which was retirement
money from hard-working [ __ ] people
who never really [ __ ] over anybody
nearly to the level that those [ __ ] did
but he did a show and Winnipeg so that's
cool all right I'm cool with them great
great research anyways you should come
to kelo kelo kelo nah Jesus Christ Kelo
w na Kelowna British Columbia next time
you hit British Columbia Jim Jeffries
sold 4,000 tickets in a city of 120,000
what Jim Jefferies is a beast Jim
Jeffrey says it hit television show Lea
he's an international actor it's a city
that appreciates good comedy
that's all I love Jim Jefferies if I
said that enough times in this podcast
and [ __ ] I had so much fun with him on
David Spade show you know I felt like I
was the the like I don't know I feel
like when I went on that show usually if
I go on a show I'm the person saying
something that's gonna get me in trouble
and then there's somebody like from a
sitcom sitting next to me like a ain't
gonna die on that hill buddy and then I
end up feeling stupid like why did I say
all that [ __ ] I should have been like
that guy next to me I felt like the guy
next to me on the show sitting next to
Jim Jefferies Jim goes in and I love it
all right Kentucky war video dear bill
didn't hear you talk about this ABC
aired footage to show how bad things are
in Syria but turns out they used
doctored footage of an explosion in
Kentucky just an honest mistake I'm sure
what the [ __ ] all right now this is in
the New York Post I mean I the New York
Post in the Daily News there are a
couple of rags that lean really hard
ABC News airs purported Syrian war video
but it's really from Kentucky oh my god
I mean did Jim
what's-his-face Vince McMahon wouldn't
do [ __ ] like this ABC News issued an
apology after mistakenly airing
purported footage of Turkish forces
bombing the Kurds in Syria video that
appears to have originated from a
Kentucky gun range
but what gave it away all the white
people in the trees Kentucky you know
what I don't know what Syria looks like
hang on a second I am a product of
Western schools you know I know what
George Washington's [ __ ] belt buckle
looks like but I don't know what Syria
looks like in 20 [ __ ] 19 Syria images
it's all gonna be [ __ ] war and [ __ ]
alright let's let's let's be a little
more fair to Syria Syria ba you guys for
beautiful beautiful places oh my God
look at that that looks like the [ __ ]
strip on Vegas okay yeah this does not
look like Kentucky I got to see this
[ __ ] footage that's hilarious not
hilarious it's actually kind of said
sadder than you not knowing what Syria
looked like where the hell did it go I
lost it
is this ABC breaking into my computer
trying to cover its tracks
I literally just [ __ ] lost everything
Jesus Christ oh no this is var normally
where I would [ __ ] hit pause but I
don't give a [ __ ] cuz I got you know
what I got a backup it's like I have a
shitty starting pitcher but I got a
[ __ ] hour long video here coming your
way
a Kentucky war video okay here we go all
right well let's [ __ ] see it then I
want to see it you know in defense of
ABC I don't know what that may not look
like anything that's going on in
Kentucky
that took place at a Kentucky gun range
Jesus Christ this is a bunch of rednecks
shooting at some bottles of bourbon you
know what's funny is we all make fun of
them and as the weather gets crazier and
crazier I think that it people are gonna
act more and more crazier and those
people who's kidding no they're the ones
that are gonna survive okay all you
[ __ ] on your high horse liberals you
gonna want to know a couple of [ __ ]
Trump supporters
hey that's a TV show somebody make that
all right it's set a little bit in the
future and too [ __ ] phony liberals
have to [ __ ] well then I'm just
saying that phony because they're
liberal but two liberals have to act
like they like these Trump supporters so
they could [ __ ] survive the
apocalypse I mean right there I mean you
got fish out at wet spot out but up and
the woman's got to sit there and act
like she hates Hillary as she talks to
the [ __ ] chick in the overalls boot
oh wait y'all from you didn't grow up no
Goods all right
ABC issued an apology after mistake the
airing purported footage of Turkish
forces bombing the Kurds in Syria video
that appears to have originated from a
Kentucky gun range how did that
somebody's figure that out the dramatic
clip first aired on Sundays World News
Tonight this wasn't local news this
wasn't some Ron Burgundy [ __ ] this is
the made man with the headline slaughter
in Syria you know what I bet the [ __ ]
dude who shot the video a border town
bombed by turkey Turkey military
anchored right aboard of town bombed by
Turkey military anchor Tom llamas says
this poor bastard like he picks out the
video this video right here appearing to
show turkeys military bombing Kurd
civilians in a Syrian border town the
footage which shows heavy
fire aimed amid a dark night sky also
appeared on Good Morning America the
next day but an eagle-eyed sleuth
pointed out on Twitter that the fiery
scenes appears to be have taken from a
2017 night shoot that the Knob Creek I
knew there was bourbon involved gun
range in Kentucky the red face network
hey don't get mad man you just [ __ ] up
all they mean embarrassed Network issued
a correction on Monday on Twitter okay
let's see how they just [ __ ] glossed
over this really quickly
correction we've taken down video that
aired on went on World News Tonight
Sunday in Good Morning America this
morning that appeared to be from the
Syrian border immediately after
questions were raised about its accuracy
ABC News regrets the era you know what I
you know what else I regret that he
didn't bring up that it was actually
from Kentucky it was but it's in
Kentucky an important part of the
footage I don't know what whatever is
this podcast is gradually starting to
just [ __ ] depress me like I don't
understand like there seems to be like
no standards anymore in like journalism
and I have to think that I'm part of the
problem considering somebody like myself
can reach so many people and not really
read anything alright Kanye hey Billy
global tits love your Netflix special
paper tiger thank you so much I recently
listened to Kanye West's new album Jesus
is king my wife my laughs just
downloaded that and she was watching his
live concert at the Forum and really
enjoyed the music just so just so you
know I'm not Christian or black I'm
Asian
alright this just took a left turn what
did that have to do with anything but
people around me are giving me [ __ ] for
liking his music here's what they say
he's black he can't say things that
dismisses the oppression of the black
community and still thinks he he'll
thrive what he can't say things that
dismiss the oppression of the black
community and still think thinks he'll
thrive I don't know what that means
well cuz he wore a trump hat and you
can't separate him from his music his
beliefs are what he projects into that
and he probably believes people should
do the same or shouldn't care
his nonchalant he's nonchalant and you
shouldn't support him as an artist hey
buddy you got to get some better friends
it's like hey man I'm just listening to
some music
this guy goes on to say or lady I
doesn't really study the way says I
totally disagree I think he's a great
artist he is for sure a crazy person
ranting all kinds of stuff that doesn't
make any sense but that's personal when
I listen to music and when that music
affects me emotionally I think it's
great yeah there you go
can I appreciate his music and contempt
as a condemned all the crazy [ __ ] he
does would love to know your thoughts uh
yeah absolutely you kid because for all
the stuff he's been you know crazy [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] he's done like what is
it affected people got upset on social
media and then made it about themselves
and then after that what happened what
legislation was passed because Kanye
said some crazy [ __ ] nothing all right
nothing which is why I don't know why
celebrities do [ __ ] like that here's
what I think about this is I talk about
the Middle East every [ __ ] podcast
lately all right whatever I'm a
hypocrite okay the monday-morning
hypocrite okay meeting girl at church
meeting a lady hey Billy [ __ ] tits see
everybody what are you what are you
talking about Oh what makes me wonder me
makes me you have [ __ ] tits I mean
[ __ ] I bet I'm a better [ __ ] shape
than you are
I love the podcast and think your comedy
is great I'm a 25 year
old guy all right yeah you're in better
shape than me and my girlfriend of four
months recently broke up with me
all right man
that probably stings a little bit be at
25 you're fine get out there have a
couple of rolling rocks start talking
some [ __ ] you'll be back in the game
it's stung he said look at that I called
it but I probably would have broken up
with her eventually anyway well then
that's just your egos hurt it's not yet
because we're very different people and
she never wanted to do anything out of
her comfort zone and didn't put much and
didn't put as much effort in as I did
anyway I'm looking to get back out there
and meet more women I'm in a new city
and I have a few ideas about how to do
it I'm fairly confident I can still get
laid going to bars and clubs but I kind
of want to meet a girl I can build a
relationship with I've always believed
in doing some sort of activity rather
than going out to bars because there's
always that chance you meeting a booze
bag right smoker [ __ ] lunatic or
whatever if you joined like literally
just stupid [ __ ] a softball league stuff
like that where there's other addicted
by the way if you're looking to meet a
lady [ __ ] like that this all kinds of
[ __ ] like I never knew this because I
always just went out and acted like an
idiot but like there's all kinds of
[ __ ] young adults that are out doing
healthy [ __ ] and they put together
groups because they also want to meet
somebody and get laid you know you ever
see those clusters of people riding
bikes
I mean someone could meet their wife in
the middle that clusters your starid in
a spandex cover to ask oh and you know
what I could picture a couple of kids
coming out of there that kind of looked
like me
and next thing you know you know you
wring your little [ __ ] Bell ding ding
ding ding you [ __ ] up the peloton no
fraternizing in the peloton right you
get up there Hey
can't help but notice that you got a
Univ a go I also have a univariate you
know he's just strike up a conversation
that that's what that's what I would do
anyways this idea of meeting them at
church popped in my head the other day
while I was dry
I like most of the ideas church preaches
don't cheat don't kill anybody bla bla
bla bla bla
o every religion starts off the seven
deadly sins of the greatest the ten
commandments you can't know the biggest
atheist in the world cannot argue with
those well I'm sure they could anyways
the problem is I'm an atheist he says do
you think it's a good idea to try to
meet a girl at church if I don't believe
in that [ __ ] uh well you're kind of
presenting yourself in a way if you show
up there it's kind of funny maybe if
you're up front just say listen I'm
actually a theist but like I was I like
the way people that go to church carry
themselves now that would piss her off
in the first date though I would think I
don't know you're kind of going in a
little that that's a big surprise early
on you know that's right up there with
the third nipple
so so I would have to say I don't know
that I would do that or I would go into
they're saying that you're an atheist I
wonder if you could actually join the
group and just be like yeah I'm an
atheist but I just I'm trying to meet a
nice woman that I could settle down with
then she might want to take you on like
you know she can solve your spiritual
dilemma I don't know the comedian me
wants you to do it I don't want you to
hurt anybody just come in there you know
like a gunslinger I don't believe in
your Christ stuff but I do believe in
how you live your life
I won't snicker when you talk about
curing lepers and you don't give me any
advice when I take out my pouch of
tobacco or do you have any tips to meet
a nice girl for a relationship buddy I
have been with my wife forever I I
wouldn't even begin the amount of
technology that has changed I met my
wife before social media
when you actually had the ball yeah that
balls to [ __ ] walk up which I did she
rejected me like [ __ ] nine times I
was hilarious then founds like you know
I [ __ ] this chick and then I went to a
bar I saw I was just like out of hell
with her and what did she do came right
up to me right up to me [ __ ]
ridiculous
you know women are like cats you know if
you try to [ __ ] and pet them they run
away but if you [ __ ] ignore him
they're all over you my ex was my first
real girlfriend and most of the girls
I've been with have just been hookups or
short flings I got a late start in the
game with women thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself dude let me tell you something
you got your whole [ __ ] life ahead of
you all right
I would go to bars I would play softball
I'd ride a bicycle I'd go to church I'd
[ __ ] do it all who gives a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] with some old 51 year old
bald redhead has to say to you go out
there and have a good [ __ ] time
all right you're in a mature place if
you want to try to meet someone to
actually be in a relationship with but
you know don't limit yourself there
might be a gem in one of those bars who
knows but I you know that's all I know I
sort of was about sports when I was
growing up and that's how I you know I
and I was amazed to meet women on the
subway I don't know why somehow I could
[ __ ] hit on him in the subway I was
always good at the gym but I sucked in
bars I was bad bars cuz I think they
knew it was coming and then I can you
know so they came and there to get hit
on and they didn't want to see me coming
over here with my [ __ ] red afro Hey
over under rated underrated amphibian
pets who doesn't love something that
thrives on land in water well get a
[ __ ] Range Rover why does some frog
have to live in a goddamn [ __ ] beer
stein sure the upkeep is terrible but
who doesn't love a good scene I think
Patrice loves fish tanks would you ever
get any lizards no I wouldn't get any
fish either that's like you know I don't
involves water is just like it's just an
expensive [ __ ] hobby or it's
expensive with your time I mean the
amount of [ __ ] time once you get that
goddamn fish tank and then you got to
get you gotta clean you got to get the
[ __ ] out of there and then is this fish
compatible with that fish and what's the
[ __ ] pH balance of the [ __ ] water
you know I'll tell you right now anybody
who has a [ __ ] fish tank out here in
LA with earthquakes is out of their
goddamn mind [ __ ] all of that I you know
I I don't want to you know I would never
have a lizard alright I grew up around
enough people who were shut down
emotionally I don't need to recreate it
in a human [ __ ] reptile relationship
okay I like dogs that's what I like I
like cool ass [ __ ] dogs you know what
I actually had a buddy of mine he police
tell me this didn't shut off off thank
God a buddy of mine I was hanging out
basically had the the chocolate brown
version of my dog Cleo well I got to see
for a week and a half which was [ __ ]
awesome technically still my dog cuz I
still pay for her it's a long [ __ ]
story oh Jesus um but I like that you
know I love a [ __ ] friendly pit bull
I'll take that over a lizard any goddamn
day I'm not like that I got I don't get
the [ __ ] snakes and all that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] slimey they don't give a
[ __ ] they kill you if they could
dogs are actually you know dogs you know
are your friend and you know if they're
not your friend a little lizard you have
no idea and that's why you know if
you've went over a real big insult on a
pond a person is that they're like a
they're a lizard person or they're
they're if they're [ __ ] reptilian and
all that it basically means that they
don't have any you ever like sites do a
bit about that like if I was ever gonna
get killed by an animal I would want it
to be a mammal because at least they
show [ __ ] emotion when they're doing
it they [ __ ] making all this goddamn
noise
they kind of put you out of your [ __ ]
misery for the most part grab you by
your throat and chomp down until you
know they put you in a [ __ ] rear
naked choke their mouth as a postage I
gotta tell you that that [ __ ] you
know I'm still trying to shake off the
last time I went on the Rogan podcast
and that [ __ ] that he shows about
animals that wanted to hit that one of
the Komodo dragon swallowing that
[ __ ] monkey hole and it was just like
the lack of expression on that thing's
[ __ ] face and the way that they they
go after those those giant goddamn Bulls
over there you ever see that one where
he just [ __ ] the Bulls just standing
there like an [ __ ] rather than
running away from the thing he kicks at
it a few times it comes up and it bites
him on the leg and once it bites him on
the leg the dragon knows that thing's
gonna die in like [ __ ] I don't know
how many days but it just knows that
there's so much bacteria his mouth the
things [ __ ] legs gonna get infected
the [ __ ] shed it just knows I bit it
it's gonna die it doesn't know about
bacteria sorry so and then what ends up
happening is what is the bull gets
weaker and can't stand anymore there
becomes this critical point where the
bull can't defend itself anymore and the
dragon feels it's safe enough to go in
and begin eating and the [ __ ] thing
isn't dead yet so [ __ ] reptiles I know
you guys are all gonna [ __ ] send me
try to send me videos of that [ __ ]
bear attack and that goddamn deer I
already saw it
I don't give a [ __ ] I'm not watching any
of them I I don't I don't like watching
things suffer anyways alright that's
that's going to be the podcast here for
this week it's a little bit short but
know that you got a little over an hour
of a video podcast coming I'm very
excited about it and and that's a maybe
I'll go to Vegas and I'll bring the
whole family that could be fun right we
could all be out there having a good
time you know my wife and kiddo hanging
down by the pool I'll check out the
Vegas night against the York Colorado
Avalanche we're having a hell of
season already maybe I could do that
knock it out you know I got some gigs
coming up man I got two more NBA teams
I'm knocking those out and I got three
more NHL teams to see and I've seen a
home game of all every franchise in all
four professional sports I haven't been
to every every stadium because like I
said last time I went to a Phillies game
they were still playing in the vet
that's how long ago that was so I still
to see their Stadium I saw the Senators
at the [ __ ] are at RFK wait a second
by the way what is that series ID last I
saw it was two one two one [ __ ] the
[ __ ] was I gonna say two one
Washington Jesus Christ I get it I got
some text messages Washington Post no
National that I say senators national
sorry oh my god Houston has tied it up
no they didn't it's three two Jesus
Christ this whole [ __ ] series is
flying by wait a second so the Nationals
won the first two Houston must have won
Game three Nationals win Game four and
then Astros win Game five
[ __ ] I'll tell you right now Josh Adam I
is is dying a thousand deaths watching
this [ __ ] one
alright that's the podcast I'm gonna
upload this [ __ ] and go [ __ ]
yourselves enjoy the live podcast I'll
be posting when it's going to come out
and I'll check in on you on Thursday